what's going on everybody and welcome to
a Q&A video about you guys so I get
asked fairly frequently about various
questions about my channel audience just
in generally their numbers or you know
countries gender this kind of thing so I
thought it'd be kind of cool to combine
all of those into a single video we're
gonna go over stats both from the
YouTube channel as well as Python
programming net let's get started so the
first thing we're gonna look at is this
graph from December 4th to March 2nd
2015
so basically a 90 day window of the
YouTube channel just as it was kind of
early days getting started as we can see
here really not really anybody from the
age group of 13 to 17 then 18 to 24 it
starts to pop and then the biggest group
is 25 to 34 a few people 35 to 44 and
then it you know kind of trails off from
there but even some people apparently 65
years old so or greater so that was
things getting started also the male to
female ratio is 5% female 95% male so so
yeah that's things getting started I
think it's pretty safe to say the
average viewer age is in their 20s so
we're talking college aged males for the
most part which kind of fits the bill of
a programming channel especially back in
2014-2015 so continuing along now we're
going to jump the same stats only the
last 90 days more current so December
4th 2019 to March 2nd 2020 first thing
to note is females are now up to 10% of
the viewership still a minority a lot of
times your viewership is going to mimic
the Creator now that's not always the
case but chances are if you're a male
creator you're gonna probably have a
male audience if you're in your 20s your
audience is likely to also be in their
20s and and so on so some of that can be
described that way although I do feel
like like Python programming dotnet as
you'll see soon the main traffic source
is organic so these are people who just
search so I feel like that's a probably
better representation of the male to
female ratio which we will get to the
other interesting change from before
till now is the age group of 18 to 24 is
now the largest group I think you know
18 to 24 is like so 25 to 34 is really
your graduates right these are people
who are done with college as opposed to
18 to 24 these are actually your college
students so this is just more people I
think in in college that are focusing
more on computer science so anyway
pretty interesting moving on to the next
stats we have the countries so this is
again from 2015 the same 90 days back in
2015 we can see no surprise the United
States is number one here and like I
said for some reason this seems to be
slowly changing on YouTube but if you
were a YouTube creator wherever your
location was was who YouTube would tend
to recommend to view your videos for a
very long time
I think that's changed now but for a
while that was kind of the case so
United States UK India Germany and
Canada kind of the big five here there's
more people on the list but anyway so
that is 20 basically basically 2015
moving on though to today we could see
India is now number one life not by far
but considering especially my location I
suspect that this trend will only
continue no real surprise India is
obviously a massive population country
also India is kind of waking up
technologically in terms of like getting
people into programming and stuff like
that and really getting into industry
including more service-based industry
like programming jobs so not really too
surprising it'll be definitely
interesting to see like in the coming
years what what what the India
representation especially on a channel
like mine is gonna look like the United
States is still number two and I'm kind
of curious initially the United States
was 28% India was seven and
India so it's almost like India just
took the place of the United States but
viewership just overall this is up so
it's really gains everywhere it just is
India gains are the most a couple other
interesting things is if you look at the
other big five countries the United
States Germany Canada these are all
people watching over four minutes right
so the watch time average is over four
minutes India is really three minutes
like India appears to be about 75% of
the watch time so all the lots of people
from India have already like close out
of this video shouts out to the Indians
who are still watching you guys are the
best so moving on to countries so again
we're looking at the Centex youtube
channel for basically the last year so
the year of 2019 pretty much every
country is touched there's a couple of
countries in Africa not hit but other
than that we're looking pretty good
there and then and then all obviously
you can kind of see here I think the
colors are not not the best because I
think India in the US should be like the
most so I'm not really sure what the
dark color is like it doesn't look like
dark should fit on the scale at all but
but anyway moving along this is you're
subscribed to not subscribe
ratio so the YouTube the centex channel
is about 33% so a third of you are
subscribed two-thirds of you are not
honestly I would think this number would
be way worse than it is given how much
my channel is organic based so most of
my but sometimes I wonder is that like
you know is it the chicken or the egg
kind of scenario because most of my
views come from organics so people are
searching problems they're finding my
videos they watch the video they they
move on right they don't subscribe so my
question is is are most of my viewers
that way because that's just the nature
of the beast or are my or is it the
other way around
we're like just because something I'm
doing is wrong that that's just that's
all the viewers that I'm getting is
organic right so you never really know
but I suspect it's just at least myself
included like I'm not following really
any one programmer instead I attended
just Google my problems I find a
resource and I move on
so okay continuing along so now we're
looking at countries for Python program
you net now Python program and that
serves way more users than the YouTube
channel does so this is really no
surprise again nope this time truly no
country is not touched here so that's
that's pretty cool like it's still
something I kind of grapple with
understanding is like the reach of
Python programming net in the YouTube
channel it just it just seems crazy to
me and even yeah the the top one which I
guess is India is 886 thousand people
that's insane that's just insane that's
a lot of people and that's uniques by
the way or is that views I think that's
actually views that's probably not
unique but we will get to unique soon
enough
moving along we have active users for
about a year so this is kind of the the
trend of activity over the course of a
year so the one day active users is
about 9600 people so that's that is
unique users over the course of a week
eighty thousand different people are
using and this is Python programming net
over the course of two weeks it
basically doubles and then over the
course of 28 days 300,000 people again
that is just unfathomable to me like I
just don't understand how the reach can
be that big but I I mean that's just the
age of the Internet I suppose but you
know whenever people ask like wow why
don't you go try to you know be a
professor somewhere and teach computer
science like at a university or any
school for that matter this is why
because this is crazy
I could never do that I could never have
that much of an impact at you know
teaching you know you you get a lot more
one on
one time which there's something to be
said about that but I think the impact
is way better there anyway that again
crazy crazy so now we get to
demographics for male and female on
Python programming at net which is like
I was saying I think on YouTube because
like your the people who watch you the
people who relate to you tend to be
people like you so it's no surprise to
me that the female watch rate is
different than the female like on the
YouTube channel it's different than the
one that we're seeing here so in this
case it's basically 25 percent female 25
percent male over the course of the last
year also the age demographics were at
least on Python programming on net
strangely enough is 25 to 34 is the main
range now I can't quite explain that one
I don't know I just be taking guesses I
guess maybe the 18 to 24 people are more
likely to watch video format and then
the 25 to 34 are more likely to just
read it and move on no idea no no clue
what's going on there okay then we've
got traffic sources so this is again for
Python programming from are people
typing in Python programming and that
and getting there or or people being
referred or are people goo you know
doing some sort of duck duck go search
or what and in this case we can pretty
clearly see that the more than 75 or 75
yeah more than three-quarters is coming
from just organic search so as you can
see here this is again over the course
of a year organic search is just by far
the most traffic that I get it would
have been interesting I wonder if maybe
I'll add it in later to see the organic
search for the YouTube channel I'd like
to see that is that also like 75% so I
don't think I did that
yeah so direct is the next one oh this
is behavior
this is bounce rate dude well that
explains it
oh what a dummy okay anyway mmm so yeah
these are the real numbers so yeah
organic 79 so I guess that tell
again the people who are searching
they're finding you organically they get
the answer to their question and then of
course they bounce they're not gonna
continue going through they just wanted
to answer that question
so yeah that's hilarious I really
probably I usually film like around 1
p.m. and lately I've been filming in the
morning and I'm not sure that's working
out for me I just can't think right so
okay so yeah organic search almost 80% I
mean that's that's so many people that's
crazy and then direct is 9.5 so not very
much so people are not going to Python
program that on a daily basis all by
themselves social eight-point-two no
surprise and then referral I can't even
see how big that is
okay so yep and then obviously like paid
search and stuff like that is nothing I
don't market or advertise for YouTube or
Python program in that this one's an
interesting one this is the most viewed
pages on Python programming net as you
can see the home page is number one no
surprise secondary is the machine
learning tutorials that is just the
machine learning page on Python
programming net and then coming in hot
at number three reading CSV files in
Python thanks corporate America I know
who you are yeah that's such an old
tutorial feel bad for everybody finding
that one they need to be finding data
analysis and they need to be going to
the pandas tutorials but they're not
maybe I should probably have like a
redirect or something there anyway so
yeah so yeah these are the ones I mean
no real surprise machine learning number
one introduction to Python 3 is very
close Python fundamentals that's kind of
where the basics are so no real surprise
there and then yeah just go from there I
am surprised how popular OpenCV is
especially considering how bad my OpenCV
tutorials are so that's kind of funny I
definitely need to redo those if you
want to learn OpenCV currently the best
place to do it is PI image search comm
and I don't understand what search
results I'm ranking higher than Adrienne
in that case but
somehow I must be so yeah so yeah
interesting you can kind of pause if you
want to look at the rest of those but
you should get a pretty good idea there
and then this one is a fun one this is
where you can take the ISP of the person
who is accessing your content and you
can filter out to some extent the major
Internet service providers and you can
figure out companies because they're
usually on their own kind of unique
corporate or commercial line so for
example my number one viewer is after
filtering for major Internet service
providers so this is getting rid of
hopefully most individuals and we're
looking at companies only here
Microsoft number one like 22.2%
so someone let me know if Microsoft
somehow is providing Internet in masse
to people other than at Microsoft cuz
that's a lot of people that's pretty
crazy no surprise like AT&T slips in
like a million AT&T calls themselves
like a million different things I'm
confident that's just 1880 internet you
got Intel Amazon digitalocean Cisco
Google I mean you could go down the list
I mean basically every major company you
can usually find yeah and I think I
found like Tesla what do you think Tesla
was looking at like Oh self-driving cool
oh no yeah anyway so yeah that's a fun
one apples on there Bailey every every
company is pretty much on your I went
through the list but you can see here
this is like their actual feel like the
Microsoft one is a 2% of my whole
viewership is I mean that's like the
viewership of some countries okay so
that's a that's a big number so that's
pretty crazy to have that much but as
you get down this list you can see it's
like 0.22 and so if as you start going
down so it's not really that many people
and I believe this is over a year's time
I'm not really sure yeah it's one point
I think that's about right users one
point five million a year something like
that we'll see in a second
so yeah straight users oh so that would
be like six months then I guess oh yeah
this is okay so this is over the course
of a year but we've filtered so we ran a
pretty massive filter but as you can see
even after filtering all that you run
out of filters that you can keep adding
so I just ran out of options but so yeah
about half the users are filtered so
yeah and then there's weird ones like
this space is statically assigned I
don't know how that happens as your
internet service provider but hey
whatever okay then finally the meat and
potatoes
what's the numbers so for this must be
Python yeah Python program internet 3.5
million
this is users not views so three point
five five million users over the course
of a year that is nuts
that's freaking nuts guys that's nuts
and new users which is interesting I
guess these are new people over the
course of a year's almost the same
number three point five sessions 6.1
million so that's pretty good maybe two
users yes number of sessions per users
is 1.7 - not bad not bad
12 million pageviews so it's like it
says pages per session 1.96 so I guess
people tend to come back twice and view
two pages at a time when they come back
okay view duration two minutes 29 not
really too surprised given my own habits
I don't think I spend two minutes on a
website when I do an organic search for
something find the result and move on so
pretty interesting well I think that is
all of my images I'm trying to think if
I've missed anything for you guys but
yeah that is the that is all about you
so if I've missed something or whatever
feel free to ask below maybe in the next
Q&A I will cover it otherwise this video
is sponsored by me yet again for the
neural networks from scratch book if you
want to learn how that works work and
you're tired of applying
cookie cutter models - honestly cookie
cutter problems so problems that have
already really been solved for you if
you want to actually learn how to go out
and use normal networks on your own and
understand why something is working or
why something isn't working even more
importantly the normal numbers from
scratch book will teach you like
everything you could need to know about
neural networks because it's literally
from scratch in Python no libraries we
eventually use numpy just because numpy
makes a lot of sense but no tensor flow
pipe torch or anything like that so and
even though we use numpy we show how to
do things in raw Python first so if you
want to learn more about neural networks
I just can't think of a better way to do
it the book is available for pre-order
right now at n NFS which is short for
neural networks from scratch so NFS dot
i/o you can pre-order the book if you do
you get access to the draft which allows
you to comment basically in line so you
can read the draft and then if you've
got questions or comments or whatever
you can just kind of highlight a bit of
text make your comment there and either
me or Daniel who is the co-author of the
book can help you out so if you're
interested it's again n NFS dot IO the
draft is current currently at the time
I'm recording this basically everything
from building the neural network to back
propagation so basically full circle and
then now we're just kind of talking
about things that go wrong mostly at
this point so definitely check that out
if you're interested
otherwise I will see you guys in another
video